this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money
your mental wellness
your relationships your boundaries your
career your job we talk about you right
here in front of you it's called the
ramsay show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
call is free and some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it we're
gonna start with gene in denver hey gene
welcome to the ramsay show
just retired from my job i'm collecting
a pension of about 5 300
but it has a condition where i could
take less 25 less and keep that for my
wife should i pass and that would be
about 3 900. and the advice of called
take out a universal life policy with a
long-term care writer to save that 1300
to pay for the insurance uh do you think
that's why i've got a paid for house
i don't have any debt i'm debt-free and
i've got about 750 000 in my savings ira
i missed you you kind of cut out when
you said where that horrible advice came
from
my financial advisors oh you need a new
one you have an insurance salesman
right yeah
um he's not a he's not a financial
advisor he's an insurance salesman
because he's selling whole life no one
else sells that crap except people that
are in the insurance business so now i
if you want to buy some insurance what's
your net worth
uh it's 1.1 million
okay and how much of that is the house
about 400 000. okay so you got 700 000
in investments
roughly
750. it all depends what my house would
go for
he said that i could invest in the whole
life so that it would be tax-free to
convert my 401k into factory should i
die
it would be tax-free
convert your 401k into what
into a life uh universal whole life
uh well that's what if i die yeah that's
true because you lose all the money
so usually when you lose all your money
it's tax-free so no you need to get away
from this guy he's horrible
uh his advice is horrible
uh no you need to keep your investments
in real investments and then when you
die your wife will get the investments
and if you want to supplement the level
of net worth that you have
should you die you can do that with some
term life insurance for a short period
of time how old are you
i'm 15
58 okay so when you're 65
you're gonna have 1.4 million dollars in
investments assuming your money is
invested in decent growth stock mutual
funds
yes it'll double about every seven years
when you're 72
you'll have
uh
2.8 almost three million dollars in
investments how's your health
my house is good good okay how old is
your wife
she's uh two years older than me she'll
be 60 in a couple months okay so what
we're doing is we're saying if your
pension disappears
right because you died
what does your wife need that your net
worth does not now provide
and so 700 000 would create maybe 60 or
70 000 worth of income
um if something happened to you what's
your income today
i'm retired i'm just i'm just collecting
my pension of uh 30 and about four
thousand dollars okay just under four
thousand and that's why i could take the
whole thing at 53.
but if i die
she would get nothing yep and we're both
in good health it's just a matter of
playing the odds yep i'm taking the 53
and if you want to play it if you want
to play a math game you invest the
difference in that in 3 900
and you buy term life insurance out of
some of that difference and you will
come out with a lot more than this goob
is offering you with this horrible
policy
um yeah i'm a long-term care writer no
you don't need a long-term care writer
if you want if you don't tie long-term
care into life insurance it's a gimmick
and they overcharge for it if you need
long-term care just go to an insurance
broker and get long-term care insurance
right okay i figured i would have enough
with with my
my retirement so here's the thing if you
go into a nursing home are you going to
burn through this nist egg and leave her
with nothing
if the answer is yes you need long-term
care insurance
if the or leave her with not enough
so
since you're concerned about it i might
buy a half million dollars in um
life insurance term life insurance for
five years or ten years
something like that is if you're getting
good health it's not going to be that
expensive and at 60 i would buy some
long-term care insurance but in the
meantime i'm not
here's a good rule here's a good rule
here's a good rule
never
use
a life insurance policy as an investment
vehicle 100
of those
suck
mathematically
100
it's kind of like saying never do payday
lending ken it's like saying never there
is never a case where leasing a car
makes sense that's right there is never
a case where going into debt at 18
interest on a credit card makes sense
there's not one
you're not the exception snowflake these
are all stupid things they go in one
bucket the stupid bucket and just never
never never never do that so thank you
for calling i'm glad you called
hopefully i helped you avoid a hundreds
of thousands of dollars mistake here i
would keep the full pension and if you
want to buy a little bit of term and
later on buy some long-term care
insurance that's what i would do as
separate policies never bundled
yeah i think what you laid out for him
is actually alleviating all of his
concerns and they're not bad financial
decisions he's healthy at 58. he said
seven years from now he's gonna double
so if he gets it to 65 i mean he's got
everything taken care of and they're in
good financial shape i think they're
clearly living below their means anyway
well they've done a great job
a millionaire yeah so here's the thing
on both of those insurance policies
insurance is what you buy for one reason
only
to cover something you can't cover
yourself
so if you're broke
stone cold broke and you have a 5 000
car
you need to cover carry insurance on
that five thousand dollar car collision
because that car being total is a
catastrophic financial event because
you're broke
if you've got 350 000 cash in your
checking account
and you're driving a 20 000 car and you
don't want to carry collision
you can afford to write the check to
replace a stupid car
so that's a that's an event you can
choose to insure or not to insure
so with your case here's the thing
long-term care insurance is this the
average nursing home care stay is 2.3
years average cost right now is about 95
000 a year so we're talking about
somewhere around 250 000
so if you have 4 million dollars
you don't need long-term care insurance
on average you're going to go through
250 000 for your care mama's going to be
just fine
when you die
financially speaking i'm sure she'll cry
but financially speaking
my wife is actually planning my death
and it's got me very concerned
i just need to say that out loud in
front of her oh sharon loves dave we've
been we've been married almost 40 years
and all of my estate plan is predicating
on me pre-deceasing her and i don't know
how she knows that so that's bothersome
but the uh uh so yeah the same thing
with long-term parents the other thing
is so in his case if he wanted to if
she's okay with 700 000 to cover nursing
home and or cover death
him and loss of income they don't need
any insurance correct if she's okay with
that i think they might be a little slim
emotionally i'd probably beef it up
because it didn't cost that much i would
for a short period of time this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five chris is in
springfield missouri hey chris welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave this is a honor to be on the
show here well thank you how can we help
i got i i want to know your opinion on
uh
okay
i bought at my first house last summer
me and a couple friends
renovated it according to my realtor
we increased the value by about 50 grand
and i have some aspirations to become a
small-time landlord
i was wondering if it's a totally dumb
idea
to
get a heloc on my current house
for a down payment for a second house
and turn the first one into an airbnb or
a rental yeah
chris how old are you
26. good for you cool and what do you do
for a living
i'm a plumber good okay so when you say
we did this renovation do we own the
house or you own the house and your
friends help you with
renovation i own the house and they
helped yes so it's completely in your
name
yes and the house is worth how much
roughly 160
after the fact
and so you think you could sell it for
um
160 and you owe like 110.
i have about a hundred grand about 100
okay so you got about 60 equity minus
expenses all right cool
all right yeah well in fairness as i
answer the question
when i was
to tell you who's answering the question
when i was uh
23
24 years old i started buying and
selling real estate
using the nothing down
real estate techniques
that were promising back 35 years ago
they're the same ones that are out there
floating around today telling you to buy
real estate and get rich in real estate
and so i didn't have any money i started
buying real estate i started borrowing
all the money to buy all the real estate
um i got rich
by the time i was your age at 26 i had
four million dollars worth of real
estate starting from nothing
and i had over a million dollar net
worth
uh the problem was i had no idea
the influence of debt on that situation
and i was flipping houses that's what i
was doing i was fixing them and flipping
them
i actually hired crews to do it i know
how to swing a hammer but i was choosing
to do more volume than my hammer would
do by itself and so i just would set up
a crew or hire a painter or hire a
plumber or whatever to get the different
rehab things done on the houses i was
fixing and flipping
some of them i was holding as rentals
and so i tell you all of that to tell
you i aspired
at that time to do what you aspire to do
now it's what i wanted to be is what you
want to be fair enough
yes
what happened was the bank got sold that
i was dealing with to another bank
and they looked over and saw that they
they felt like this 26 year old kid owed
them too much money and they called our
notes and we spent the next two and a
half years of our life fighting through
severe banking technicalities that i
didn't even know existed
and losing everything that we owned
we were sued we were foreclosed on and
finally we were bankrupt
at the bottom of that i started studying
how money works
and i started talking to old rich people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him i didn't want his
advice it didn't work
and old rich people started telling me
this thing called common sense
and as a christian i started studying
the bible and it talks negatively about
debt 100 of the time
and so i figured out that this debt
thing didn't work and i started buying
my i bought my first piece of real
estate after that with cash it took me a
little while
because it's hard to get the cash
together
and you made some quickies you made some
quick easy money plus or minus your
sweat in this house
but it's been fairly quick and it feels
like you could do it all the time well i
did it a lot
i did it a lot
but it still came crashing down around
my ears so that's the guy you're talking
to
he not only wanted to do what you're
talking about but he did it
and i did it with debt and it backfired
on me and it wasn't that i was stupid it
was that debt is stupid
and so all of that to answer your
question and say no
i would not borrow on a heloc to go buy
a rental
uh i would keep working like a crazy man
as a plumber i'd get this house paid off
if you're going to live in it
or i would sell it and take fifty
thousand sixty thousand and buy a tiny
little cheap something and flip it
with cash
and if you wanna do some flips with cash
i'm in i'm fine with that especially
where you're swinging a hammer and some
of your buddies are doing the renovation
with you and that kind of stuff that's
all cool but i'll tell you now i own
that was 35 years ago that we crashed 30
years ago that we crashed 35 years ago
that
story started
and uh today i own several hundred
million dollars in real estate the
building i'm sitting in is worth a
hundred million
and so uh and it's all paid for 100 i do
not borrow money for anything ever
after that experience so
i tell you a big long story to give you
a really solid no
don't do that
yeah you know i love the point you make
he's a young guy and if he's not living
in that house
flip that
and and get an apartment yes sir i don't
mind you renting and flipping sir but
pay cash that's right okay he's off to a
good start there if he flips that now
yeah and it's good time to make a little
money if you can get in one of the deal
very difficult to find a deal right now
yeah
like i'm almost impossible needle now
hey i was shocked at how how much that
house cost yeah but um but you can do
that and it's possible in springfield
missouri i mean that's a it's a great
market
and i i want you to go live your dream i
don't want you to let it turn into a
nightmare and it has for me oh and by
the way there was a whole bunch of
people did nothing down real estate then
i was actually in a nothing down real
estate club
back then chris that had 150 members
let me tell you how many of those guys
are still doing real estate deals with
nothing down
zero let me tell you how many of those
guys went broke
all of us
all of us
all of us went broke
no one made it out using that technique
now i do know one guy started selling
the properties off taking the equities
and paying off the others he ended up
with a portfolio about one-third the
size of his original portfolio
downgraded about 70 percent but turned
out with cash he went the other way from
the nothing down to 100 debt free and
he's still managing those properties i
ran into him the other day but the guys
that persisted with this nothing down
bull crap stuff that sold in these
weekend seminars
100 failure rate a decade later two
decades later so i want to stay there
dave because it's still being sold and
it's being glamorized on social media oh
big time so what's what are they not
telling them they they're telling you oh
you can do all this but there's
something they're not telling they're
not properly portraying the risk
what's the what's the hidden information
they're not sharing the the nothing down
deal only works if everything goes
perfect and nothing ever goes perfect
that's it
risk
debt equals risk more debt equals more
risk
if you owe a hundred thousand dollars on
on something that's a lot more risk than
if you owe one thousand dollars on that
thing
so more debt equals more risk 100 of the
time because you got to carry it if it
doesn't sell you got to carry it if the
fed decides to jack up rates oh wait
that happened you got to carry it if
there's a pandemic oh wait that happened
you got to carry it even if you lose
your job because of the pandemic oh you
got to carry it even if there's hyper
inflation so it freezes the market like
a deer in the headlights oh these are
real freaking things that happen
and they happen to me you got to carry
it if the president changes the tax
legislation and change it and flips all
investment property on its head ronald
reagan completely destroyed the real
estate market while i was in the middle
of it i'm a ronald reagan fan but worst
presidential decision he made completely
undid the investment real estate market
by flipping the
uh
flipping the
depreciation schedules off
changing the value of real estate with
one stroke of the pin and it turned it
turned the snl business on its head back
then the savings and loan industry
and you can't control that crap because
you're not the president
and it it affects
things out of your control come in and
and
make you stupid when it's stress tested
always reveals itself to be stupid you
can tell it was skinny dipping when the
tide goes out
that's what they don't know
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america one of
the most important types of insurance
you have is of course car insurance
it's actually the law
maybe even motorcycle insurance if
that's your thing most americans don't
have enough car insurance
and you're probably one of them if you
get into an accident you don't have
enough insurance you'll have to pay for
your own car repairs medical bills the
other drivers car repairs and their
medical bills and their passengers
medical bills it can cost you thousands
and thousands of dollars
even get you sued
you've got to have the right car
insurance and that's why we created a
network of endorsed local providers or
elps they're licensed independent
insurance agents
which means they will shop around and
get you the best deal among a bunch of
different companies
and get you the coverage that you
actually need hello they'll teach you
how to understand your car insurance a
lot of people pay for car insurance just
mad about it don't even know what they
got
you need to actually understand what
your freaking money is going to
yeah if you're ready to work with an
insurance agent who actually works for
you not for the insurance company
visit ramseysolutions.com
auto to connect with the ramsey trusted
elp ramseysolutions.com
auto eduardo is with us in los angeles
hey eduardo what's up
hi thank you guys for taking my call
sure how can we help
yeah my question is to ken today i um
it's about a career advice i am
looking into getting into college
um
and so i'm pretty clear on what i want
to study um
and i always hear him talk about the
bethel tech school of technology um
and i just need some advice if you know
since college right now is
starting to become more irrelevant for a
degree
and so i don't know
so what direction do you want to go you
said you know what you want to study
presumably you know why you want to
study that where do you want to go want
i want to get into engineering software
engineering computer science space yeah
well specifically what would that look
like your first entry level uh what's
that going to look like you know the
industry well enough to know what
entry-level work is going to be
um
mostly it's the coding
gotcha and
yeah so here's the answer uh computer
science degrees or many computer degrees
they're never going to roi for you
based on the fact that you want to go
into developing and coding
you don't need to do that bethel tech
obviously they are a big time partner of
the ken coleman show in fact we just got
an email this last week
the first ken coleman show grad to get a
job making over a hundred grand just
happened
and he is a recent graduate of their
nine week program that's one example
there are a lot of other coding boot
camps you need to do your homework on
reputable boot camps you know call
bethel tech but talk to other folks do
your homework because the reality is
to get a four-year degree and in some
places that could be as much as 180 000
for some computer science degrees it
just does not roi you do not need it
google has announced a major initiative
where they are training future
developers future engineers because they
know that they can teach people what
they
need to be able to work for google and
so
it does not require a college degree not
to go the direction you want to go and
so
less time less money is what you're
looking for here and so don't feel the
trap that i have to go to college to
become a developer yeah um eduardo we've
got at ramsey solutions we have uh
software engineers
uh
dev ones twos threes uh we've got
architect and platform people uh all in
the space that you're talking about
totals over 400 folks working on my team
i pay millions and millions of dollars a
year in salary and income to people like
you want to be
and i would i i'll just tell you 100
we do not require a four-year degree to
enter that field
100
if you were going to hire you to do code
to be a software engineer
to to write java to write ruby whatever
it is you're going to write
all we want to know is can you do it
and we're going to run a code test on
you and if you can code we're going to
bring you in and the level you code at
is the level we're going to pay you out
not what you think you are whether you
think you're a dev one or you think
you're a dev too our guys we've got you
know professional executive leadership
in this area that hire people every day
i will hire probably 60 or 70 people in
the coming 12 months in the field you're
talking about and we will not require a
four-year degree from a single one of
them
all we want to know is can you code all
we know want to know is the background
that if you have any if you have any
experience that proves you can code
if you can pass the test showing you can
code if you have the certifications from
something like bethel tech or microsoft
or whoever showing you know how to run
the technology then you're in
technology is not driven by that the
only time you would get a four-year
information systems or computer science
degree is if you're going to want to go
into a very high level of leadership
where the actual coding doesn't matter
because by the time you get a four years
if you're graduating today with a
four-year degree the stuff you have
studied in college is already obsolete
because it changes
almost by the minute yeah
what they need to study uh and so being
in the field having your hands in the
code makes you much more valuable oh and
by the way it's four years of income
making a hundred thousand dollars that
you're missing out on too yeah not only
are you going to pay somebody 180 grand
so this is a five or six hundred
thousand dollar conversation we're
having right here yeah and listen i
believe in four-year degrees
if you if you ask me if you need to go
get a four-year degree in marketing i
would say yeah or a four-year degree in
business or accounting i'd say yeah go
do it i think it's worth it there's
going to be some superfluous classes in
there but it's worth it you'll get an
roi on that it makes sense it's it it
you know and it's going to give you
literal lift uh but i got to tell you
you come in here to interview you got a
four-year degree in information systems
or you got three years of code
experience as a software engineer i'll
take the code experience over the
four-year degree 100 of the time now i
think we're going to interview the rest
of the person and learn about them too
we're not going to rule out the guy with
a four-year degree right we're not
calling you an idiot for having one but
i'm just saying it does not even give
you a one-up no and and let me also give
an alternate path for leadership in this
space too
because i've seen it happen here at
ramsey solutions it's happening
all the time where we'll have somebody
come in uh as a coder and they do great
work we realize they've got great people
skills or otherwise known as soft skills
you hear this in the marketplace all the
time and and they because they follow
well they get the opportunity to lead
and so you could you could go to a boot
camp a bethel tech like this get in do a
good job listen to the entree leadership
podcast buy the entree leadership
bestselling book written by dave how do
we lead how do we teach leadership here
at ramsey solutions and begin to follow
well and work your way up the leadership
ladder as well it is possible so the
long and the short is eduardo go to code
school don't go to don't go to college
not for this particular path not for
this path yeah doctor yes i wouldn't if
you were my son i would tell you no
and so and then when you graduate from
code school take a dev one position and
keep going to coach this is the key it's
a very important point just because you
come out with this this quality you're
not going to have three when you're
getting out of school take the entry
level position the young man i was
talking about dave he was in a
non-technical uh technology position
making sixty thousand dollars he just
got a hundred thousand dollar
entry-level position as a dev one death
cult code school on only under his belt
with a nine week program at bethel tech
which by the way ramsay solutions
because we pay cash our our audience
you're gonna get it for less than 15
grand yeah so that's not an ad for them
you could go anywhere coach school well
i tell people check everybody out you
can choose them they're great we
wouldn't endorse them if we didn't think
they're great but it's everywhere but
you know our guys all the time i mean we
even talked about opening a code school
yeah just because our need is so high
and really that's all they need to know
how to do to get in to get their foot in
the door and then they can grow from
there and we can teach them the rest on
the job in an apprenticeship type
situation because our dev3s coach our
dev ones every day they write code
together oh yeah and they'll pull them
up and teach them and so that's that's
how you learn this particular thing it's
it's like a modern day version of a
trade like welding or pipe fitting and
i'll tell you this dave the industry the
data is out there on this if you are one
of these you know brilliant developers
and you've got good people skills
there's no stopping you yeah because uh
most developers don't they say it point
blank no they don't have people skills
that's not what they do most of them are
you know game on with the with the ones
and zeros that's it yeah yeah so it's a
great space though dude and i got a
bunch of them on the team and we love
them we love them they're great people
and uh they care very deeply about their
work they're wonderful we it's a great
interaction we have here at ramsey with
them this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host this is the ramsey show jacob is
with us in seattle hi jacob how are you
i'm doing well dave penn thanks for
taking my call i appreciate it sure
what's up
all right so um me and my wife uh are
currently have no doubt uh looking to
purchase a house in the upcoming
couple years we have a little bit of a
disagreement on how we are going to be
saving the money um i'm
i have a higher risk appetite than she
does i would like to put it into
like a diversified etfs and try to get a
little try to get the money to work for
us for
the upcoming few years before we
purchase and she would like to put it
into a high yield savings account so we
know exactly where we're going to be
in three years
how would you suggest to go about
finding a compromise with that
well i think what you both need to
realize is that this decision is not
going to keep you from buying a house
or cause you to be able to buy a house
so let's do the math for a second i'll
show you what i'm talking about
how much are you talking about saving
um
we would like i would like to purchase a
house that we're going to be in for the
next 30 40 basically our lifetime so
good luck with that but yeah it usually
doesn't work that way but but how much
are you talking about saving in the next
three years
uh about 200 000. okay
and so if you make 10
on this money you're gonna make 20 000
bucks
if you put it in a high yield savings
you're going to make nothing
and you'll lose 20 000 bucks
but 200 000 is what's going to cause you
to build buy the house
and 220 is not going to cause you to buy
a substantially different house
so the fact that you made a little money
on your money is more of an intellectual
exercise than a factual change in your
situation
okay that makes sense i'm following you
okay and so
uh and the same thing's true with her
let's say you put it into an etf and it
did not make 10 a year
you had a bad three-year run in the
stock market stock market in general was
down you got tagged
you know in the face with this thing
which could happen in a three-year swing
and uh you don't have 200 000 you end up
with 180 000.
so you actually lost money you follow me
still doesn't keep you from buying a
house
so my point is your concern that you're
not making a bunch of money is somewhat
mathematically invalid her concern that
you're going to lose so much that
you're going to not be able to get a
house is also
not really mathematically valid this is
all more about emotion than it is actual
dollars
okay yeah that makes sense i'm following
you yeah so anyway all that to say
how do we solve this
uh
probably at our house
uh we'd probably end up splitting the
baby we'd probably get let me do uh put
a hundred thousand over in investments
and she'd put a hundred thousand over
there and at the end we would see who
won the bet
so you would say put it do a 50 50 down
the middle yeah yeah i don't think
there's anything wrong with that at all
because but again
before you do this both of you need to
really own the fact that this is not
going to cause you to buy a house or not
buy a house
it's just more of an argument over how
we park the money
so i i got to weigh in here
you know look i i think you do exactly
what dave just laid out walk her through
that
both sides of the coin then i would see
how she's reacting to that and if her
safety
gland is still flaring
i'm going with mama you know what i'm
happy wife happy life what's the other
alternative that's the other alternative
yeah you don't lose on that one
because if you win if you put it all in
there and you go down 30 grand i told
you that's gonna cost you 30 years yeah
of remembering that
yeah that's the truth and maybe some
jewelry it costs you a thousand dollars
a year in memory that's my remember back
in on 23 when you didn't do what i said
do
i remember
they have memories oh they are
memorizing elephants have nothing on
women yeah this is true they remember
ever especially when they're right
that's even more devastating which again
if you want to just most of the time
that's what you need to come to that
conclusion as well so this is not even a
mathematical question find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her
and he will have no lack of gain so at
our house we probably today we would
split the baby 20 years ago when we were
still a little fresher
the the nerves were still a little more
raw after going broke yeah we probably
would have parked it yeah in a high
yield savings and we're not taking any
risk because sharon
was so
terrorized yes emotionally by what we
went through
that it took a decade for her to go and
we had to have a big old pile of money
to where she could go oh if you screw
that up over there it ain't gonna kill
you and she's still one of the most
frugal people i know oh my god the woman
will pick up an old used golf ball right
like no one i have ever seen we have a
collection of old used golf she's over
the weeds
she's gonna get bit by a snake
getting getting a golf ball that's worth
50 cents because it's already been hit
by the mower yeah it's unbelievable the
woman is uh yeah yeah she no frugal
frugal don't even touch it yeah all
right and and that's a compliment that's
a total kind of a compliment my darling
eric's in new york city hey eric what's
up
how you doing dave better than i deserve
man how can i help
yes um i
have credit card debt about 25 000
and two of them total 20 000. my credit
union is offering
a 1.99
uh to and i was thinking about
refinancing it
uh those two larger debts because it's
about 400 in interest that i'm paying
every single month while i'm doing the
baby steps i'm on baby step one
so you owe you
you owe forty thousand dollars on
plastic
no i owe twenty five thousand on plastic
oh twenty five
right two of them total 20. i got you
okay and you're gonna you're gonna
refinance 20 of the 25.
right okay and uh
what do you make a year
100 okay over 100 you know it's odd this
is the same conversation we were just
having a minute ago but he was on the
investing side and you're on the death
side
you can do this if you want to do it
here's the danger
you're going to think you actually did
something
you think this is a big deal
you don't have a four hundred dollar
problem my man
you have a 25 000 problem
when you address the 25 000 problem with
the idiocy spending you've been doing
like you've been in congress on plastic
when you address that deep down in your
soul you're going to get out of debt
really really fast on 25 000 making a
hundred
you're not gonna be in debt very long
interest is not your problem
but if you want to lower the interest
it'll help you a tiny bit here's the
deal five percent of you getting out of
debt is refinancing this 95 of you
getting out of debt is you're looking in
the mirror and getting pissed off
and chunking on this thing and beating
the snot out of it because
mathematically 95 of this is not going
to be an interest problem mathematically
this is going to be youth chunking money
on this because you're mad you're sick
and tired of being sick and tired i'm
not living like this anymore
you are 95 of the secret sauce that that
level of
you hearing me dude
yes so how long would it take if i just
left it
two months longer
you saved two months
i might have missed that by a few days
one way or another but my point is 400
is 4 800 a year
and you're gonna be out of debt in a
year and so
uh you know we cut it in half because
halfway through the year you're going to
have the debt half paid down so it's not
4 800 a year you're going to save it's
going to be more like 2 400 a year in
this year that you get out of debt in
one year
and so you're saving 2 400 bucks 200
bucks a month at the end of the day and
how fast does how much does that apply
to a 2500 oh i was right it's 10 there
we go look at that so yeah you know
so it's probably it's between a month
and two months you're going to say it's
okay to do it i'm not mad about you
doing it but what i don't want you to do
eric the thing people do with that
consolidation is they feel like they did
something and they think they fixed it
with this loan and you cannot borrow
your way out of debt
yeah i mean
that's what they're selling is saving
money and then you kind of lean on that
instead of the intensity that you're
talking about and you you have this
frustration like i gotta get out of debt
and then you think you did something and
then you look up a year later and you're
still in exactly the same place i got a
lot of lower payments you gave me a line
what's that he doesn't have an interest
problem he has an intensity problem
that's what you're teaching that's a
good line well you gave it to me i like
it i didn't say it you said it i'll let
you have it take your notes over here
folks you can own it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your money your job
your career your mental wellness your
relationships your life right here on
the show triple eight eight two five
five
two two five is the number columbia
missouri starts off this hour ob is with
us hi obi what's up
hi dave hi ken thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
well i just want to start by saying that
uh
we're debt-free uh paid off our home
mortgage uh late last year and we're
hoping to get on the debt free stage is
one of these days great how can we help
well i have uh two questions uh one i
received a letter
from my 401k one and it says that uh the
irs service requires plans to pass
non-discrimination tests each plan year
and it says the test place
percentage limits on the amount of
amount a highly compensated employee may
contribute
and have allocated to the 401k so
basically it gave me some money back
saying that i over contributed
because i guess some people in the
company are not contributing to the 401k
correct um so i guess my question is uh
does the irs set this limit
or can a company decide
what they consider as highly compensated
employee no there's a formula the irs
sets a formula it's a regulation in the
401k regulations that say
uh it keeps all the big bosses from
making a pile of money and dumping it in
where the little guy's not putting any
money in and the big boss is just using
the 401k to screw over the little guy
and that's what it's for that's why it's
there uh but it the the math you know
you know can really work out big time
against you so you are in the highly
compensated category
and uh and so that means that you do not
have enough participation
with the uh folks that are not highly
compensated in the 401k that are medium
whatever how big a company is this
it's a
family-owned home improvement retail
store got about over 300 stores
so what 5 000 employees
uh
probably more uh okay the place where i
work has about uh 177.
okay
okay
yeah you're just l you're just limited
it's that simple you don't have any
control over the situation and the
guideline is not it's not arbitrary it's
not set by the company it is a formula
that the irs regs hit and basically what
you're telling me is this retail
operation and so you got a lot of
turnover at the entry level position so
they don't ever bother with the 401k a
lot of them working part-time jobs that
kind of stuff and so it's going to keep
this thing screwed up one antidote is
for them to bring in something like our
smart dollar classes where you teach the
employees how to handle money get them
out of debt so they start their 401ks at
any level
uh and we've got
companies your size and companies small
and large all across america that are
doing it for instance costco all of
their employees have gone through our
smart dollar and so they you know and
it's basically the financial peace
university type lessons on getting on a
budget getting out of debt and that
enables people to begin investing then
and shows them the importance of
investing and so
it's really
a very cool thing so you could talk to
them about talk to your leadership team
about bringing in something like smart
dollar because education
and getting people out of debt so that
they can invest is the answer to the
formula long term but that's probably a
two to a three year process to get this
to where you're still where you'll pass
the non-discrimination test and the
discrimination is not racial or
sex discrimination the discrimination is
math
discrimination it's high-income earners
are discriminating against low income
earners or medium income earners is the
concept that's what the word means in
this context i also want to point out
dave that recent studies show that
employees want financial advice and
guidance from their employer that's
something they're looking for so what
you've got here is also a tremendous
benefit for companies like this not just
to
help the individual in that situation
but to keep people staying with them
longer you're going to build loyalty
it's a real perk and a lot of
individuals i mean you have to
understand if if an employee looks at
their employer and says you help me get
my money life in order
um they're going to be happier they're
going to be more effective at work and
they're likely to stay with you much
longer this is a straight up benefit
that people are looking for and smart
dollar is poised
to be able to help right now
we were the first ones in the financial
wellness space i own financial
wellness.com
so we were the first ones there and
teaching companies uh setting companies
up to be able to teach their team
how to handle money whether it's got
five people or five thousand people or
fifty thousand people but i gotta tell
you ken it's fun when i go to my local
costco over here and i'll walk through
and uh the guy or gal checking out my
stuff is like seeing the videos hey dave
what's going on man thank you man yes
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool i
get recognized sometimes in different
places but that one feels pretty good do
they ever follow it up with really dave
you really need that many ribs you
really you really hey you really need
that much water seven cases of water i'm
going the lake house i'm going lake
house all right here we go
seven gallons of peanut butter amanda's
with us in minneapolis hi amanda how are
you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
i'll try to keep i'll try to keep it
brief um with the housing market going
on my husband and i have about 285
thousand dollars in equity in our home
we've always done the work ourselves so
our house is kind of ballooned and we've
never pulled equity from it
so we carry very little debt um after we
would pay our debt off we would have
roughly 144 000 left over
we're just trying to figure out if it
makes sense to sell we're in a good
financial position we own an electrical
company we make good money
so we really don't need to sell but my
husband's really entranced by the idea
of putting a lot of money into savings
and buying our next house pure cash
what would you advise
[Music]
you know
if your if your net result is that the
two of you can find a home
that you like as much
and you end up with zero mortgage
and you've taken advantage of this white
hot market and it causes you to be able
to do that
that's okay
if the end result is that you end up in
a house you don't like because your
husband got all flipped out about this
real estate market that is not a good
result
right and that's my worry um we do own
some commercial properties he wants to
for a couple years live in one of the
commercial properties which i'm not
completely sold on nope and nope
it's just nope yeah we'd have to go back
into renting for a couple years because
yeah so
you're not broke
you're not broke
he's just going too hard time dial it
back a notch
you're going to make plenty of money
you're going to have plenty of money
you've already made plenty of money
and this house is going to do nothing
but go up in value from here
you don't need to live in a warehouse
so he can take advantage of the market
nope right i got to tell you sharon
ramsey's not doing that crap yeah it
ain't happening
and i i love i mean i like taking
advantage of a hot market i'm i'm with
you on that idea
but this guy he's just pushing it over
the edge and he's going to cost him back
down the road later new
nope he may be debt-free but he'll be
sleeping on the couch in a warehouse
exactly
down by the river
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
over the last 30 years we've walked with
millions of people in their families to
help them work hard and overcome their
financial stress
money stress is one of many kinds of
stress all of us experience people
struggle with anxiety with loneliness
with stress
with mental
wellness all the time
and here's the good news dr john daloni
has a new book available for pre-order
called own your past change your future
it is selling like crazy i just got the
sales report on a minute ago as a
pre-sale right now it's going crazy it
comes out in april
and if you pre-order own your past
change your future you are going to get
a free bonus which includes the
audiobook the e-book and a month of free
one-on-one
weekly therapy through our partners at
better help
this is a real bargain for twenty
dollars own your past change your future
for twenty dollars you do need to get
his new book it is incredible at
ramseysolutions.com pre-order it so you
get all
the bargains
blinds.com is our question of the day
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from laura in florida i am
studying interior design and i have been
doing some work for free for a friend
who is already a designer to get
experience recently she asked me to take
on some time intensive projects i would
like to be paid for these projects but
am unsure how to ask since i have been
doing other work for free how do i ask
to be paid for these larger projects
well the simple answer is clearly and
nicely right with a with a good helping
of humility here the challenge is uh uh
you started out working for free which i
wanna first say dave a lot of people
uh in today's environment and i'm not
gonna go on a rant here but they they
just look down their nose at
getting themselves in by working for
free and it's all about i deserve the
dignity being paid and this is the way
the world works so i applaud laura for
getting in and doing some work for free
but now the friend who has said okay we
got some new projects um i think you
have to sit down and go hey
i i'm so grateful that you allowed me
this opportunity
you lead with gratitude always gratitude
always lead with grateful for this uh it
has been invaluable to me these projects
seem to be
a lot more time intensive and because of
that i'm wondering can you pay and what
could you pay me for these because this
is going to eat into the other areas of
your life and this is what i mean by
clearly don't speak in gray black and
white so that and don't your friends
understand
around the edges
here's how it's going to affect my life
for these time intensive projects could
you pay me notice how i'm stating this
could you pay me and what would you be
willing to pay me and we have a
conversation not a negotiation this is a
friend who's already done you a real
solid and i think if you go that
direction and that kind of posture and
when i say posture i i don't mean the
physical posture i mean the emotional i
think if you do it the right way
your friend's gonna let you know what
she can or can't do and then you have to
be a big girl
and decide what you can and can do
here's the thing anytime
any of us
are in a conversation with someone
that is uncomfortable or awkward
we tend
to in the name of being nice
do a ballroom dance
all around the issue
instead of just saying what it is that's
right it is a lot less painful
and kinder
to be just cut straight through it and
very calm
lower your voice tone your volume
everything
and just say
what it is
uh i mean whatever the situation is just
say it yeah and it takes the air out of
the room and and
otherwise all this ballroom dancing adds
to the awkwardness
and i i did this and and you guys would
think well dave's always blunt well you
know what i've gotten more blunt i've
gotten more direct because of this idea
and because early on in our career you
know we had folks working on the team we
had maybe a team of 20 people or
something like that someone would be
screwing around they wouldn't be doing
their work they'd be off track or they
weren't good at it or whatever and i
would get continually frustrated and
they never knew it
because in the name of being nice
i never told them that they sucked at
what they were doing right and it wasn't
nice
because i got more and more and more
frustrated until finally
then then i would there would be a i
wasn't ever mean to somebody but that
would be like this one little thing and
i would hit i'd hit this little number
one with a 10.
and they're going where'd that come from
well it came from six months of me
putting up with you not doing it and and
but i never said anything because i was
nice that's the key and that's just bs
to be unclear is to be unkind
and here's the deal if we don't fill in
the blanks for people they'll fill them
in for us
and they're there therein lies the
frustration well are you talking about
dance they're going to think it's worse
than it is
but
that's the other thing they're trying to
read your mind you're trying to read
theirs and it just gets into this weird
thing versus this is a friend this is an
easy conversation i know
where laura's coming from it feels like
they're going to reframe this just
all it is is you did some part-time work
for free yeah and it's over that's it
yeah it's hard oh and there's another
chance here to do some more work but
it's not gonna be free that's right you
just need to go thanks for all the
thanks for letting me come in here and
learn this stuff and hey i'm not gonna
be able to work on this to other stuff
unless there's pay involved because it's
it's just too much and but thanks so
much for letting me do this lead with
gratitude close with gratitude
make a gratitude sandwich man i mean by
the way the backside of this folks if
laura goes in with that posture and
she's been tremendously valuable to her
friend and her friend realizes she's not
working for free anymore great chance
that she scraps some money together to
hire laura so going in free and adding
tremendous value you never know what
that could lead to i'll give you a 50-50
chance to almost think about paying her
anyway i think so i mean you know she's
actually she you know unless she's just
trying to take advantage of her uh cody
is in bend oregon hi cody welcome to the
ramsay show
hey pleasure to talk to you you too
what's up
um so my wife was in an accident uh a
vehicle accident
um going on a month now wow yeah am i
okay
no bumps and bruises whiplash that kind
of stuff
but there's still a whole so that's good
um
so the van that she got hit in is
especially equipped with handicap van
with ramps and
tie downs and all kinds of stuff for
special needs daughter so you get you
got one in a chair
well
most of the time i mean typically she
rides in the front seat
thank goodness in the accident she was
in the front seat and buckled in and
she'd been in her chair i think it could
have been a lot worse
um a long story short
we're in a little hatchback four-door
rental car that we have to fold the seat
down to put our wheelchair and walker in
so that makes the car compatible for two
people yeah
so michael did you have insurance on the
van
we did we do in the and the driver fault
did okay so you're gonna get your check
well unfortunately he's only covered up
at 25 000.
what was the van worth
well in 2015 we paid 76 000 for it i
didn't ask what it was worth in 2015.
ask what it's worth
well that's we're still waiting to find
out
um
no you don't need to wait to find out
you need you know what it's worth
well we got a letter from the dealership
um we gave them the original
sticker on it and they came back at the
value of round 44.
okay so it's a forty thousand dollar van
and you're gonna get a 40 000 check
you're gonna get a 40 000 van
you just had one go get you another one
well and that's the thing the van itself
is a unicorn i mean that was going to be
no it's not there's no such thing
vans aren't unicorns
okay i mean there's special needs vans
out there for 40 grand that are used
they got a wheelchair ramp and got
tie-downs
right
she doesn't even sit in a wheelchair
that much anyway but i mean i want you
to take care of her
but but i'm already i'm already in
running you on where you're going no i'm
not gonna tell you to go buy a 76
thousand dollar van you were driving a
40 000 van it was doing just fine
right you have a you have to go hunting
for a needle in a haystack but it's not
a unicorn it's going to be a difficult
look there's not one on every corner
every lot doesn't have a special needs
van on it but you've been living in the
special needs world you know how to
source these things
and dude you don't go into debt for this
there's no reason to you can provide the
needs of your family for 40 000
it can be done or buy a 20 000 van and
equip that puppy
one of the two
these are all possibilities we've got a
wheelchair niece and they've got a
wheelchair van
and we know they fight this stuff it's a
hard thing you're fighting but it can be
done and don't use it as an excuse to go
into debt it's not
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in boise idaho caleb and katie are with
us and it says on my screen that they're
debt-free way to go guys
how are you how much have you paid off
and nine 99
and thirteen cents i'm just gonna call
it a hundred way to go
how long did this take
38 months 38 months and your range of
income during that time
102 000 and now we're at 143 000. cool
what do y'all do for a living
i am working finance
i'm an analyst
yeah and i own a roofing company ah very
good good very good so what kind of debt
was the one hundred thousand dollars
you know we were very normal
we had a forty five thousand student
loans fifteen thousand on a car
uh 12 000 on a hvac system and then
credit cards and hospital stuff and
[Music]
things yeah you had quite a collection
yes we did
yeah you were normal well done good job
knocking this out
so uh how long you been married
10 years
i almost said that yeah that it takes
about 10 years to make a mess that big
yeah yeah yeah
and then we got we'll start listening to
you and and uh decided it was time to
change
yeah
so the radio show woke you up
yes okay then what happened you went
okay that guy on the radio sounds weird
weird weird wait a minute we need to do
this what'd you do yeah we had uh my dad
pushing us pretty hard towards it for a
while and we kind of you know kept
calling him crazy and then then we
started listening to you and uh it all
kind of made sense once uh once we
started listening and hearing other
debt-free screams was a big help and
all that good stuff yeah okay wow
so uh your dad is pushing you which
makes you kind of push back and go nah i
think i'll be my own people we're gonna
be our own people
and then you look up one day and going i
gotta do this and the worst part about
it is i gotta tell him i'm doing it so
uh
yeah so katie whose idea who was i
started talking about this first you
were caleb
it was me i we had kind of talked about
it he had mentioned his dad saying
things and then i just
started listening to it the student
loans were mostly mine and they made me
literally feel like i was in handcuffs
so
um i just wanted to be done with them i
just wanted to have more freedom in my
life and it was pretty emotional thing
for me but i started listening to you um
more and
hearing those debt-free screams i just
i was it was one of those things where i
was like i didn't feel like it could
ever happen but i also knew it had to
oh caleb so the story now unfolds your
dad is after you now your wife is after
you yeah i had to come in and you got it
from both sides man you had no choice
bullet and uh
and i just decided to agree with the
wife eventually
he's a wise man
yeah
good job dude good job well done all
right so you you're listening to the
debt-free screams and you're going okay
hope hope hope we can do this hope is
coming and what was the first thing you
did out on a tactical level practically
to start making this change
it was actually uh
january 1st of 2019 we've kind of been
talking about it and i told him because
i i paid all our bills and so
i just told him we have to sit down
together and really look at what our
debt actually is because i knew there
were a lot of things that were kind of
coming in but i never wanted to look at
it all together because it was so
overwhelming
um
and
we got home from a trip and caleb was
like okay let's sit down and do it and
that was such a big moment because we
kind of talked about it but him saying
like let's sit down and look at it
it made it honestly was like an instant
relief just having him in it with me and
then
we wrote everything out and it was
pretty much from there we were just like
let's do it yeah so when you wrote it
all down and you saw it was a hundred
grand 99 400 and something
what was your
first
reaction uh holy cow
i think she edited that it might have
been a little saltier than that
yeah it might have been but i don't know
if it's radio appropriate
holy day batman
then you start to run the math back
against it going we make 102 we can make
143.
and you start going oh wait a minute we
can do this
yeah yeah that was a big thing too we
were like we make we make a decent
amount of money how are we not seeing
any of it how are we so tight every
month yeah how is it we make six figures
and we're broke
right yeah exactly boise freaking idaho
i mean my god yeah yeah it shouldn't
have shouldn't ever be the the case uh
here and uh for a hundred thousand yeah
we should have been
living high on the hog but uh it was
every month you know worrying about what
bill we're gonna pay next and uh yeah it
saved our marriage too
as far as getting on the same page and
and looking at everything and budgeting
every week and really being a team yeah
yeah i want to know was there a moment
where you saw the momentum where either
you you had a conversation and maybe one
of your budgeting meetings because you
just described you guys laid it all out
and it seems like you were on the same
page at that point when did you
experience that feeling of we have this
we're going to be able to do this let's
go
i think after about like a year and a
half in we decided to do financial peace
university and because we kind of we
were like motivated and then we lost it
just like a little bit we're like let's
do this and i feel like after that we
were like holy cow like we really are
gonna finish this wow yeah the first
year we really hit the ground running
pretty hard and then
you know about
in the year and a half territory we you
know we weren't
necessarily davish but we had some we
had the
you know birth of our son that we cash
flowed and needed a bigger car that we
cash flowed we didn't go crazy on that
but uh we wanted to get a nice big car
but we talked ourselves out of it
and then we did financial peace
university and uh that kind of got us
ramped back up again
and ready to i love that it's like the
runners win yeah it's a water break at
the halfway point yeah yeah that's here
we go game on again and you kick back
your pace back up and go yeah good for
you guys well done well financial peace
university serves a lot of different uh
things in people's journey sometimes it
starts them sometimes it finishes them
in your case it was the water break in
the middle that's pretty cool i love it
yeah we kind of kept saying like oh we
don't need it we've we listened to the
radio you know we listened to dave on
the radio every day and
we got this we know what to do but it
really did help uh help us a lot yeah in
that halfway spot to uh just keep us
keep us pushing and keep going way to go
guys so proud of y'all who was your
biggest cheerleader outside the two of
you
probably our kids our daughter yeah our
daughter was you know she she reminded
us all the time we need to get this debt
paid off
how old is she
how old is she
she's
seven now oh she's a little kid okay wow
very good you know
yeah she knew it was important to us and
she was she was we had the list of all
of our debts on the fridge so she would
see us cross it off and
and get excited every time we crossed
one off and
so yeah yeah i love it very cool you
guys so i'm sure your dad's dancing in
the street
yes he was very excited when we told him
we're going to be doing a debt free
screams we just found out he was texting
the whole family i love it i love it so
uh what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
it's i mean it's it's kind of cliche now
but getting on the same page with a
budget every week and getting it all
written out and seeing it on paper
uh makes a big difference and holding
each other accountable yeah exactly well
cliches come from something being the
truth that's where they come from so
it's okay well done y'all hey we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too number one
bestseller that is the next chapter in
your story to be baby steps millionaires
i just met some out here a few minutes
ago
so uh young ones too very good job you
guys and a copy total money makeover for
you to give away 100 000 dollars paid
off in 38 months making 102 102-143
caleb and katie in boise idaho count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls
i love it
man they're free
they're free
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we talk about
your career your job your mental
wellness your relationships
your money everything hey if you've done
something stupid
with money
welcome to human race
if you've done something stupid with
money you know what that makes you
over 12.
every one of us have done something
stupid with money even ken coleman oh
has done stupid stuff with money yeah
got a whole folder whole folder i i mean
i've i've made a living telling the
story of of me doing stupid with zeros
on the end i i've done a lot of stupid
things and uh years ago i i decided on
the on the air that when i do something
stupid
with money
and it costs me money
i call that money that it cost me stupid
tax
and we've all paid
some stupid tax
my goal is to never pay
the same stupid tax twice
don't make the same mistake twice
and and start calling it because at some
point it it's not making a mistake at
some point it's just stupid
you know but if you pay if you've lost
money doing something stupid with money
then you have paid stupid tax
and uh
we're going to gather up we have heard
some absolutely
hilarious
endearing
fun
and inspiring stupid tech stories over
the years
we used to do a whole hour
a theme hour of stupid tech stories and
we would just it was comedy we would all
just laugh together at how stupid we all
can be
it's not calling somebody stupid it's
calling what you did stupid i'm not
stupid but i have done some stupid
things there's a difference the big
difference it's not an identity it's not
shaming dave you're shaming people no
i'm not you little snowflake i'm shaming
your misbehavior there's a difference
yeah are you just laughing from the
lessons learned yeah i mean
by the way
might as well laugh about it and if
somebody else can get some some you know
we hear this over and over here's why i
love the stupid tech stories in some
ways they're very much like the debt
free screams you hear call after caller
people staying on our stage go i
listened i watched and i got inspired
well when other people hear your stupid
text stories and they're in the middle
of stupid they're not going to judge
themselves as much they see you on the
other side of it laughing that other guy
was stupid and so that's it's not only
entertaining it is really life-giving
yeah
it's shame removing not shame-giving
for those of you concerned about the
shaming issue oh and trust me people are
shame on you dave absolutely all respect
for you dave
i'm sorry i wasn't taking a poll
okay
stupid tech stories
we need some stupid tech stories because
we're going to start featuring them
again here on the air so
upcoming segments on stupid text i want
you to go to ramseysolutions.com ask
ramsey solutions dot com slash ask which
is actually the portion of the website
dedicated to kelly
because people send kelly messages there
and most of them are nice
and most of the messages she sends back
are nice so
it is kelly so
yeah you go to ramseysolutions.com ask
put stupid tax in the subject line
give a little brief description of the
time that you paid stupid tax and kelly
will contact you she will be nice she
will not shame you
and she will um laugh with you we will
laugh with you not at you
and um
does she when she reaches out to people
they she go hey that really was stupid
we'd love to have you on the show
that's awesome that is so stupid we need
you on the show
i don't know i don't know how she does
it we'll have to find out okay so
ramseysolutions.com put stupid text in
the subject line and you can be part of
the show will feature you either as a
caller
uh telling your story or we might even
feature it in long form and written but
if you send us like seven page emails
it doesn't translate to right it's not
gonna make it it doesn't make it one
page is one that would be
stupid well for different reasons but
yeah
all right jake is with us in st louis
jake welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken how you doing better
than we deserve brother how can we help
had a quick question so i i've been
teaching leading fpu and i just actually
just finished financial coach master
training and
i've been telling people for years about
heloc's and stuff that they've been
they're just a you know credit card
attached to your house exactly um but i
had a quick question we were my wife and
i were walking in our neighborhood and
one of our neighbors told us hey i was
looking to move but
housing market's crazy and my banker
told me i have 70 000 of equity so he i
don't think he did a cash out refinance
or whatever but
was doing instead of buying a new home
he was upgrading his home and i guess my
question is is
what is the difference between doing
that as long as you're doing it to
actually upgrade your home
and just buying a new home and financing
all that stuff already in the home
well
the biggest thing is is these are
repairs or updates you should have been
doing all along
and so they don't come at you at 70 000
in one bill
and if you can do them seventy thousand
dollars in one bill you can do them in
phases
and you can cash flow
and then you don't need to add the debt
um obviously you know from coach master
training that even with a mortgage we're
gonna teach you to get out of the
mortgage so we don't want you every time
you want a nicer home to move up in home
or to renovate your home either one we
want you to pay cash for doing either
one of those things because ultimately
we want to end up being 100 debt free so
i would reframe the approach and say
um instead of let's figuring out a time
that debt is okay let's figure i always
figure out a way to avoid it
and just not even ask the question is my
point um so i mean your neighbor didn't
ask you for coaching or me
and so but had they asked me for 70 000
bucks i i'm going to guess and say he
probably could have cash flowed that in
24 months or maybe 36 months and done it
in three projects because it's probably
not just one thing
and um
if it is a 70 000 single improvement
that's highly unusual
highly unusual now you could do a 200
000 addition to a property and that
would not be unusual uh in that case i
just move personally
uh in almost every case and you hear me
say that all the time but even when you
move you're moving into a better
property you're going further into debt
now you got to turn around and reverse
the process again and start getting out
of debt again
and so i'm always trying to figure out a
way to to stop
the borrowing
not figuring out a way that it's okay
wonder what conditions is the borrowing
okay
instead of going that way it's always
figure out a way to stop the borrowing
because see what i did jake as you know
is when i went broke i vowed i never
borrow money again
and so this is not an option for me if i
want to upgrade my house i want to move
up in-house i want to fix something in
my house there's only one method i can
use
because i'm never going in debt again
it's only one method i can use i have to
pay cash
where nowadays we've got more zeros on
some of our projects we're building a
conference center on top of the hill
here right above this building uh that's
about 40 million dollars
uh we're about
halfway through it a little more than
halfway through it um i'm at about 26
million in right now
and uh we got about a year left so that
tells me i got about 2 million bucks a
month to cash flow this puppy out the
door and we're watching it cash on cash
cash on cash cash on cash and i'm from
antioch tennessee i don't know where you
came from guys but that's a lot of money
to me that still freaks me out you start
talking about two million dollars for
something you start talking about two
million dollars a month for something
that just blows my little country mind
i'll tell you but that's what god has
said we're able to do we have the money
he's showing us to do it we're doing it
and we're going to help a lot of people
with that conference center and that's a
tool and what we're doing with it it's
not something i'm buying for personal
consumption
um
so um
you know so again if i want a conference
center
i got to rent one
i got to use something around here and
stack chairs too high
we have to have cubicles that are two
stories or something in here uh until we
can afford to do a different building a
better building because we just don't
borrow money we just took it and you
know anthony o'neil used to say it well
when he was here as a ramsey personality
you have to take debt off the table
i never said it that way before him but
it's a good it's a good way to remember
just take debt off the table so my point
is jake not
is it okay you're probably gonna be okay
but we're not trying to get to okay
we're trying to quit
borrowing money that's the new framework
on it
so how can we do this and not borrow
money
or maybe we don't do it at all if we can
this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host as we
talk about your jobs your career your
money your mental wellness and your
relationships all right here on the
ramsey show thank you for joining us
debbie starts off this hour in new york
city hi debbie welcome to the ramsey
show
hi um hi dave hey what's up i hope
you're doing well i am how are you
i'm okay i'm okay
um
so my question
um i know that i'm very new i
but i've already cut i've already closed
six credit card accounts good for you
and
yeah so and i have a question although
it's a little far in the future
considering where i am with my debts
but you say to put the to do the three
to six a month emergency funds from what
i've heard from your show and from
reading your books
after you do all your debts other than
your mortgage but i don't have a
mortgage because i rent my husband and i
we rent
and
so my largest debt is a 93 and a half
thousand dollar student loan
and i'm kind of my other debts to get
them all together the debts are like
almost 190 thousand
i'll be besides i already just cut up
anyway so my question is i'm just
concerned that they'll take me for i'll
never get to the emergency fund or it'll
take way too long if i do the student
loan before i do the emergency fund my
husband you know his income isn't 100
steady because he you know self-employed
and um you know and what are you guys
making here it's all taken up on my
debts what do you what do you make a
year
household income um i actually looked it
up last year i made 106 238. what did he
make
that i don't know exactly i just here it
is income really varies it's less than
mine right now um it used to be more
he has a steady 30 000
and then it goes up and down depending
upon how much work he has and it's uh
and um but i know exactly what does he
do
he's an electrician um
and uh why is he not covered up in work
he's 84 years old
well there's that he's um
yeah my husband is a lot older than me
okay um so he's 84. so he doesn't really
do the work himself and
he just you know backs up other people
yeah basically yeah and so
so how old are you no he does that so he
doesn't like you know so he just gets to
like a small fee you know so how old are
you
59. okay cool
all right good for you well i'm glad
you're attacking this
and in general
there's a power to focus so you've got
130 000
plus or minus income
to attack almost hundred thousand
dollars in debt
yeah
ouch
what was your student loan for
nursing and that first year two loans
the original nursing degree
then i this would be my stupid
i went for the masters but i did it as a
bridge program because i had a
bachelor's so now the masters did need
buckets
no everyone wanted me to have the bsn
but my bachelor's isn't another thing so
i feel so i have a borrower's defense
case now for that part of for that part
of loan i have a borrower's defense case
active and right now
i i'm in forbearance because of that and
even when everyone else has to pay back
their loans because the pandemic freeze
is ending
i still don't have to pay until they
decide my case right
um
so right now i'm not even focusing on
that at the moment and i don't know if
i'll win or not and if i do i'll still
have for the original degree right um
which is like so you are you are a nurse
today
i'm yeah i'm a school nurse i mean i
become an rn but i work in a school okay
all right
i have a quick question on that dave are
you maxed out with the with the
the degree you have and experience you
have as a nurse are you maxed out or
could you make more than than the 106.
um i tried to get um back in the
hospital um and no one would even
interview me well i didn't ask you that
i'm saying are you maxed out in the
marketplace cause there's something else
you can do with an rn that makes you
more than you make now
not that i'm aware of no i mean np but i
couldn't do that because i don't have
the experience in anything that you can
get an np in because i spent most of my
time in the school yeah
so i can't i can't go for a postgraduate
certificate program as a nurse
practitioner because of that right
okay and i also work for my husband's
business at night you know it's like i
work for i work all day at the school
his business doesn't make enough money
that you have to work for it much
yeah well sometimes it's busy sometimes
it's not it also doesn't even know how
to turn on a computer so i have to do
everything computer related even his
emails
like you know like some people either
only emails i have to yeah but if all of
that's making you five dollars it's not
worth it you might hire somebody to do
that it'd be cheaper if you could make
more money doing something else but so
don't get caught in that so the answer
to your overall question is uh you have
a really high
i mean you're in a pretty deep hole
with a medium-sized shovel
and that's what we always call it the
shovel to hole ratio what's the ratio of
your income to the debt and you have 130
to 150 000 household income
with 200 000 in debt
and so if we paid uh uh
50 000 a year on it it takes four years
if we pay seventy five thousand dollars
a year on it it takes three years
and that means that you're living on
beans and rice rice and beans you're
living on nothing scorched earth
below nothing in new york city to be
able to pull that off and
that's why we're scratching around here
because if we can add 20 or 50 000 to
this equation on income it gets you out
of debt a bazillion times faster
and whether or not to save for the
emergency fund is really not going to be
your problem your problem is you have
got to for the first time in your life
address this ridiculous debt situation
because it spiraled out of control on
you
and so i mean
i we can argue about or discuss the
theories of baby step one being a
thousand dollars or do you move baby
step three ahead but none of that
changes the fact that you have two
hundred thousand dollars in debt
and you've still got to address that
and so you know if you say i'm gonna
save ten thousand dollars for a little
emergency fund before i move on to my
student loan fine go ahead and do that
but it doesn't it doesn't address the
issue
the issue is you've got to do something
pretty radical and begin to attack this
debt at a level you have never
considered before
and uh and that's what we're outlining
is this intensity
and this level of sacrifice
to be able to be free and be clear
because the last thing i want you to be
is 10 years older and still sitting here
and he's gone and he's gone to heaven
you know i that's not what i want for
you
and so i want you to have a better life
than that and it's going to involve
some you know it's a big mess so it's
going to involve some big changes and
some big sacrifice to get there uh this
is not a little mess
so i'm honored to have you in my
audience thank you for calling debbie i
know it's scary and i want you to feel
free to call us anytime we'll always
help you
you keep fighting it i think you can do
it but buddy i mean you got a mountain
to climb girlfriend
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's been a long time as a matter
of fact as far as we're concerned around
ramsey way too long
since we've been able to talk about and
do our live events and we are doing real
live events with people
in them and everything and when you come
to event an event with us you're going
to spend the whole day digging into all
areas of your life money personal growth
leadership
mental wellness your career
all of it it's called the smart
conference you're going to leave hyped
up ready to make real change we
love doing the day long smart conference
it's all the ramsey personalities plus
this year our good friends craig and amy
grochelle from life church are coming to
do a section on marriage and oh my
goodness this is incredible you got it
smart conference is back it's been three
years we're pumped we're going to be in
dallas october the 22nd on saturday all
day long when you leave at the end of
the day you will be smart
you gotta love it it's our biggest event
of the year you don't want to miss this
jam-packed event rachel cruz dr john
deloney
our own ken coleman christina ellis
pedro la torre
of course
where is george campbell there he is
george campbell's on here oh i'm going
to be there
yeah
and as i said greg and amy grochelle
it's pretty incredible tickets start at
just 39
it's a great price for a full day of
smart
get your tickets right now before they
sell out they are selling very quickly
you know all these live events and
concerts anything that's happening in
mass right now is selling like crazy
all of our stuff is going really really
fast we've got an orlando wealth
building event up for sale right now ken
coleman and john deloney are going to
come to that as well
be signing books afterwards
during everything else we're going to be
out in the lobby seeing you guys we miss
being with you in all these cities and
so we love being on the road and being
out there with the peoples
so uh come out guys ramsay solutions.com
events for the smart conference october
the 22nd or if you want to do building
wealth in orlando may 19th it's on the
books as well i'm going to be telling
you about more of the building wealth
events um we're going to do one more of
those here in the spring and for more in
the fall around the smart conference
we're going to be all over the place in
cities all across america you do not
want to miss this then that the other
city might sound like this it might
sound like las vegas but i can't say
that yet no it sounds like it though it
sounds simple similar to that you know
when we make the announcement it's kind
of how it is and i want to tell people
we had a lot of new people uh joining
the show listening to new listeners if
you've never been to a ramsey solutions
event i got to tell you something man
we're not just going to give you
practical hope-filled transformational
content can i tell you how much fun we
have and we we really do try
and we succeed at letting the audience
have fun not just listen and learn but
we have fun and it's i suspect coming
out of the pandemic dave i promise it's
going to be election i promise you you
will laugh every 12 minutes and you will
cry at least once every 30 to 40 minutes
oh boy there's something i promise you
oh probably
and that's just what ken speaking
every 12 minutes
that's quite a guarantee there's someone
who made that up i know you did
yeah
but it's fun it is and you will leave
changed and you will leave transformed
and it's it's a blast
elizabeth is with us in uh charlotte
north carolina hi elizabeth how are you
hi dave hi ken i'm great how are y'all
better than i deserve i was in your fair
city yesterday speaking at elevation
church for my friend pastor steven
furtick it was a blast how are you how
can i help
wonderful um yeah so i'm i'm doing great
better than i deserved as well um and
i've got a problem my husband and i we
bought a truck
uh and we paid cash for it
but the dealership listed our bank as a
lien holder so the dmv issued the title
and sent it to the bank
so now
the dmv says they can't reissue the
title
without helene release from the bank and
the bank is saying well we don't have a
lien to release
and we're kind of going in circles here
how do i get my title back
well
this is this is that's ridiculous
okay
the dealership can solve this they can
reissue the title
or your bank can quit being stupid and
release a lien that they don't have all
you gotta do is sign the back of the
title and say the lien is released
there's no it doesn't have to be an
accounting transaction for your bank
your bank's being an idiot
how do we get the title for the bank to
sign the back of it though where is the
title the title was met
it was never issued a good question well
if it was issued with a lien holder it
went to the lien holder it went to the
bank
that's that's what the dmv told us and
the bank is saying they don't have it oh
they do your bank is incompetent
yeah
who are you bank with bank of america or
something
that's your third oh god
they're awful here we go
well yeah they're they're incompetent
for sure
and um
sorry go ahead no that's okay
yeah so here's the thing
climb all up in your banker's face and
climb all up in this dealership's face
the dealership can reissue the title
okay
i mean and and for that matter you can
call the state
what was the state telling you
the state's saying we issued a title we
don't we issued a title we've done our
job and it had a lien on it
right yeah they're saying well the
dealership told us there was a lien
which i'm going but there wasn't and the
fine purchase paperwork i have does stay
in all caps
under the lien holder box none
yeah well there should descend bailey
and you pay cash for pretty clear yeah
how much was the truck
it was 23 000 and changed
okay well what i'm going to do is i'm
going to dance on the face of your
banker
and get their attention and then i'm
going to change banks when this is over
because you have a horrible bank
and the other thing is i'm going to go
over the dealer and go guys look i
didn't do this you've got my money yeah
i don't have a title are you gonna solve
this or am i gonna have to have an
attorney contact you to solve this i
didn't create this problem it's not on
me to fix it you created this problem
it's on you to fix it yeah i i i just
don't know if the problem's not at the
dmv to be honest with you if they're
saying there's no the bank or the the
dmv is saying that the dealer told them
there was a lien yeah but the but that's
not adding up
i got to tell you that the dealer's
incompetent the dealer the finance
office at the dealership got sloppy
that's right they made a mistake and
instead of going and fixing their
mistake they're running around acting
like this is elizabeth's problem yeah so
i'm going to make it some other people's
problems and you're going to have to
keep you got 26 000 bucks online you got
to get a title
the dealer i mean this is like losing 26
000
like you lost 26 000 of my money you
probably need to find it
yeah so it sounds like the dealership
could fix it which may be a better route
than the bank just because the bank is
such a big bank maybe the dealership i i
agree with i think it's the dealer dave
that needs to fix it because that's what
they do that's the whole part this is
the problem with dealing with someone
like fifth third or bank of america
they're so big and they're so stupid and
they don't care yeah
a normal bank that cared could fix this
all that because there's no harm to the
bank whatsoever on releasing the lien on
the back of the title and releasing it
back to you even though there was never
any lien they don't have to do an
accounting entry some duber called a
banker needs to get the title out of the
box sign the back of it and send it to
you it's that simple
and the whole thing's over yeah but you
got to find somebody with a brain at
fifth third bank good luck with that
i mean that's the problem that's why i
tell people not to bank with these banks
like this we bank with smaller community
banks regional banks and credit unions
the only tell the time i tell people to
bank with people because you can
actually find a human being that a cares
and b has two brain cells
because if you had two if you had three
brain cells you would have quit your job
if you were at fifth third and gone and
gotten a good job
you know but no you're staying there
it means you hadn't listened to the king
coleman show and gone and gotten a good
job you know this is like the start of a
bad joke a car dealer a banker and a dmv
staffer walk into a bar into a car
and between the three of them can't find
a brain cell this is the triangulation
of incompetence
it's not lesser heart
that's what she's stuck in the
triangulation of incompetence you are in
the
bermuda triangle of incompetence the dmv
a banker and a car dealer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here
open phones at eight eight two five
five
two two
five so the social media team just told
me that the uh instagram account which i
didn't even know existed for a long time
um when instagram first came out i
didn't even know how to do it because i
was on twitter remember when twitter was
a big deal back oh it was there when
everybody was on twitter yeah yeah i was
on twitter and i had like a hundred
thousand people on twitter i thought it
was a big deal
and then i got to like 500 000 on
twitter and i just knew i was a big deal
then i'm joking yes because twitter does
not define you i can promise you that
and then twitter just started to
deteriorate yeah and it's all trolls now
it's a total jungle it's a it's a it's
like all
the mental illness on parade yeah i mean
it's just crazy it's like very bitter
people bitter angry it's really the it's
it's the it's the black hole of social
media
and so uh anyway so then i i just got
off of twitter i mean we have a twitter
account with my name it's got about a
million now just under a million
and uh the guys all they put stuff on
there but it's all hate all the response
is hate i could put on their free
hundred dollar bills and somebody would
go that's not enough that's right
where's mine you should for a fun
example you should tweet the sun is hot
and then wait for people to disagree
with you on that yeah yeah no well i
mean and it's uh trump's fault
right you know or i mean they just say
some dumb butt stuff on there so uh i
was not paying attention to instagram
and it got up you know like a million
half two million people or something on
there
and uh so our instagram people were like
dave you need to respect instagram
because it's legitimate the gram is
great the gram the gram oh like you're
like you're you you're in the grammar
type that was a there was a nickname for
it this is an attempt for me to be
relevant oh my god as soon as it came
out of my mouth
that was i regret saying this already
before i even finished it it's like i
always tell my kids i say check it out
on the google and it irritates oh
i do that on purpose it's just like a
bad dad joke have you got that internet
thing yeah the same yeah
so where you got big news well yes
apparently the gram i'm now i'm now
three million people on the grim
congratulations so um slow clap for that
that's yeah slow close it's like a nice
park
solid par putt there yeah but the uh uh
so
and um at dave ramsey by the way i don't
know i don't want to be real sarcastic
or anything but i'm supposed to like
it's that's nice that's why are we
supposed to sell it i'm going to be nice
i'm just going to say that's very nice
thank you for all of you that are out
there we know we've got about 20 to 25
million of you on this show out there
and uh three million of you on the gram
i didn't even know it's called this well
yeah this is what the kids call it
what's what it's what oh really do they
well or you just made that day you know
47. i don't know you don't have any
ideas
you and i together couldn't find cool in
a bucket
hey but here's the point you should be
following
ramsey on instagram because it's good
content and can call me while you're at
it apparently
give me a follow apparently somebody
cares so there you go there really is
great content out there well it is yeah
and we don't i mean but there's a few
haters showing up on the ground when the
ground first came over
it was like nice people and it was all
the irony of social media is that it's
not very social
it's things could people can be
downright mean you mean those people on
facebook aren't really my friends ken
i don't you mean they're not really my
friends not until you so they are until
you say something that they don't like
it's a little different it's like that
relationship was shallow didn't last
long
we broke up my favorite in the old days
is when someone would tell you uh
unfollowed and
as if you cared yeah well and i would
just went back and and when did i start
taking a poll
but i actually may hold the record for
the most people blocked on twitter oh
you think so it's become like a thing
with the kids to get blocked by me oh so
i quit doing it finally
because it became like i haven't been
blocked by dave ramsey i must not be
cool we should check the stuff i'm i'm
guessing it's over ten thousand i
blocked because i used to just sit in
the mornings and block them
and but now there's nobody left to not
block so you could just close the
account easier yeah because they're man
i tell you the number of people that are
intelligent on twitter is so low
it's so small
so um they're just mean and mad scary
anyway it's fun this social media thing
and yeah it's kind of all collapsing
though i mean it's being shown up to be
as fake as it is everybody's kind of
figuring it out yeah they're going like
those people on facebook aren't really
my friends
and uh and then facebook starts
throttling stuff and charging for
everything everybody's pissed off at
zuckerberg and then and the gram is
owned by facebook now you got me calling
it the gram it's not even a thing
which may be one of my greatest
professional achievements
it's up to you
you and i could work together for the
rest of our lives and not cause that to
be a thing so
uh all right mikey is with us get us out
of this mikey he's in indiana how can we
help
hello how are you
good how are you
pretty good um i'm a junior at indiana
emerging abuse administration and mining
entrepreneurship cool good for you my
name is yeah i want to start my own
business um
i'm taking a finance class right now
that we are learning real estate and how
to manage money
but i'm struggling with what my
professors teach us because it goes
against their free principles
that i believe in and learned in
financial peace class in high school
like for example some of the things that
he says is that we should use credit
cards for everything sure so you get
money back and can't rent a car or hotel
or buy airline tickets with a debit card
or cash yeah he also said you need a
good credit score in order to buy a
house and if you ask him about dave
ramsey he'll tell you dave ramsey's an
absolute idiot
oh yeah
yeah that's fine
yeah and then he said we should take our
equity in our house buy new cars he also
said that payday lenders and cars are
necessary you need to pay for something
so here's the thing mikey
he's a finance professor
okay he doesn't have any money
you're getting a degree in
entrepreneurship
and one of the things is you have to
learn to think critically and how to
avoid these situations
okay
so
what do you think the odds are that
you're going to change
anything he believes or teaches i would
say close to zero wouldn't you think ken
uh yes guaranteed i don't think there's
anything that you can do or say no or i
can do or say that are going to change
this guy's misguided
bad teaching
and bad advice she's going to continue
to do it okay is that you believe that
to be true mikey he's going to continue
to do it no matter what we do agreed
true okay so now you got to decide
now you got to decide
are you going to pass the class or not
yeah i have an a in that class just pass
the class and move on
okay because you're not going to change
the guy and you're way too smart to
follow what he's saying you know he's
wrong you've got good critical thinking
skills you've compared his advice to
what you've learned from us and his
advice came up short
and you found our stuff to be the truth
my joke always is is that i learned to
borrow money from my finance professor
in college who was broke a finance
professor that's broke is like a shop
teacher with missing fingers
i've been telling that joke for 25 years
and it still gets a laugh yeah it's
still funny because that's exactly the
case here so
here's a funny one mikey get this so my
daughter denise ramsey
at the time she was not married at the
time was taking a personal finance class
in college
and the guy not only did everything that
you're talking about but he always spent
five to ten minutes every class
trashing dave ramsey not realizing his
daughter was sitting in the room
wow
and at the end and she called me and
she's upset and she's angry because she
wants to defend me and i said darling
just pass the class
but at the end of the class make sure
you introduce yourself
and she said when she introduced herself
at the end of the class she got an a
because she answered his questions the
way he wanted them answered
it didn't change her opinion she's never
borrowed a dime didn't change anything
and then she introduced herself at the
end of the class and said i've been
sitting here
for the entire time listening to you
trash my father
but i wanted to make sure that you knew
i was here
and that you gave me an a and i want to
thank you for the a
and she said the guy almost threw up
he almost lost it he almost lost his
cookies right there so i mean that you
just got to have some fun with this dude
because you're not going to change
anything those convinced against their
will or are the same opinions still
sweet little denise because she she's
non-complicated she's not like rachel
she's non-confrontational
rachel would have been standing up in
the middle of class having a heyday
right there and we'd had to get her
she'd still be reading headlines we'd
still be reading headlines like her
father
she would make the tennessean
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 48 17 i
am the lord your god who teaches you
what is best for you who directs you in
the way you should go
albert schweitzer said i don't know what
your destiny will be but one thing i
know
the only ones among you who will be
really happy are those who have sought
and found
how to serve
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today eric is with us in austin
texas hey eric welcome to the ramsey
show
hey there dave hey ken thanks for taking
my call sure first off off the top my
wife and i have been doing the dave
ramsey plan for seven years now and you
guys have uh truly changed our lives so
i appreciate it cool and you uh congrats
on your instagram following your three
more 3 million more followers than i do
[Laughter]
thanks brother didn't change
yes sir i have one of those uh good
problems i guess my wife and i
are in baby step seven so the house is
paid off well we're fully contributing
uh to our retirement funds and things
and basically we're looking to upgrade
the house we just had our second kid and
so looking to get a a few more square
feet i guess and
right now our house is about 450 000 and
probably trying to look to
maybe the 650 700 000 range and i guess
you know what we've been doing is
putting money on the side in this
investment account and it's about a
thousand dollars a month and so i guess
my question comes down to
do i just have to wait for that little
account to be a couple hundred thousand
or
i made up a new baby step called baby
step 7b
where i pause some of my retirement and
load it all up kind of like on 3b and
try to pay cash that way and so i was
going to see
your thoughts and get your wisdom on it
what's your household income
uh it's about 145
a year
okay and so you're putting what
percentage of the 145 away for
retirement now
uh how do you know do you know the total
dollars
it's 25 000 split between two roths and
a simple ira and then we have two 529s
going as well that are uh probably about
you know five to six thousand total okay
so you're
25 on a hundred and forty five year
that's only about fifteen percent isn't
it
yes sir that's right
okay
uh and so we're saving an extra thousand
into uh
into a separate account that we're
calling house fund yeah okay so here's
the thing
if you cut your retirement completely
off
yes it still takes 10 years
yes sir
so we got to do something different
period regard the retirement doesn't
save the doesn't save the day it doesn't
okay i can do it in three years if i cut
my retirement off no you can do it in
ten years if you cut your retirement off
or eight years i mean it still takes
forever
right so we need more than a thousand
dollars
going outside of retirement
right
because i don't want you to cut your
retirement i don't want you to come i
don't want you cut your retirement off
for eight years do you
no i was thinking kind of like how on 3b
you'll tell people to do it for like
maximum of three years i know but that's
only 25 000 it's only 75 000 it doesn't
get you there
if you're gonna do it for three years it
needs to get you there
you follow me okay
yes sir yeah i totally get you in and
you know i've followed or we've we've
been on the no mortgage thing for the
last few years and i want to be there
those feel different but i mean so if
you don't have a mortgage payment why
what was your old mortgage payment
like 2 000. so why can you only save a
thousand
because you were paying 2 000 when you
put 15 away
yes sir
yeah i don't know i guess we went a
little bit more lavish on the trip how
big's the house
your current house uh seven seventeen
hundred square feet how many bedrooms
uh three okay i'm moving up if i'm you
but the way i'm moving up is i'm gonna
get a lot more aggressive on saving for
the house i think you're i think your
lifestyle is what needs to be pinched
not your retirement account
because you're not even able to you're
not even willing to save your old house
payment
is this the first kid dave i didn't pick
up one of his first kid or second kid i
thought it was first kid it was but
i was totally relaxed it's okay to move
up in house it's gonna take them three
or four years anyway they're probably
gonna have more kids right it's okay but
the uh uh but the thing is this you know
save three thousand dollars a month and
then we can talk about dialing the
retirement back a little bit but not
completely off and then you can get
there but don't talk to me about saving
a thousand dollars a month because
you're burning your money and lifestyle
you're not even saving your old house
payment towards the new house
that's wimpy
that's what i'm saying and i we're
already doing those numbers before that
at least be able to do that
i just think couples they feel like they
got to upgrade in the house because of
one kid and the point is they could have
two two kids they could share a room i
mean they just don't need to be in a big
rush here in the next year to two years
here well i'm okay if they are because
they're gonna be millionaires
i mean they got a 650 thousand dollar
house they're going to be making theirs
so yeah i'm agreeing with you they're
saying a little bit it's okay to do it
but you know but
you're not here's the thing you never
make enough money
that you don't have to choose something
to say no to right
i don't care what it is
i mean i know a guy makes 10 million a
year and he had to choose to say no
to a new jet
i mean there's always something right
poor guy
that you can say no to right erica's in
boston hey erica what's up
hi dave pleasure to be on the show
honor to have you how can we help
hi so i'm in baby step two i am 55
726 in debt i
am a mom of three kids six two and four
months and i was just wondering if it's
okay to start a family child care
business because we do want one more
child however we can't afford the
daycare costs um and this makes me a
little nervous my mom is currently
helping me take care of the kids she is
a child care provider so she has her own
business and she's looking for me to
take it over
i was just wondering if this is a good
idea while i'm still in baby step two i
am currently in an admin
i mean are you single
i am married yes so what does he make
so
combine our take home pay sixty four
thousand six hundred and eight dollars
and what do you make
uh that's our combined income
what do you make
um a year i make
um
sixty two thousand eight hundred makes
two thousand dollars
he makes two thousand dollars two
hundred and forty a month yes and i
think three thousand one hundred forty
four he currently just got a part-time
gig
um as well you just told me you made
sixty thousand dollars but the household
income was sixty two 000.
let's try again
okay what do you what is your annual
income at your job erica
my annual income is 62 800. what does
your husband make at his job annually
annually i want to say like 29 000. okay
so his job
as a carpenter yeah his job sucks
he just started his carpentry job um two
years ago so he's new but he's not
getting like a good pay right now he did
just get a part-time gig to make up for
it okay um he's looking into trade
school to be coming over
60 000 worth of income keeping kids can
you do that
you cannot i'm sorry can you repeat this
can you make 60 000 keeping kids
yes
if you can make as much as you're making
now and you want to change over to that
and you're and you're able to prove that
today you can do that immediately taking
over your mom's old business
then that's okay okay but if you're
telling me you're going to take a pay
cut
you can't afford to take a pay cut both
of you can't have a job that sucks
right exactly that's exactly what i was
worried about um i didn't know whether
to like show up more
in this business
exactly yeah that's that's the problem
right now um
yeah so it's it's a pipe dream that's
going to turn into a nightmare until you
dial the numbers in
ken
i i i really put the pressure on the
hubs here uh i make no apologies for
that he's gonna have to step up in this
economy as a carpenter only making 29
000 i've got questions
i got a lot of questions that we didn't
have time to get into but he can make
double without blinking if he puts the
effort in and he's got a good attitude
clean record what i just don't know
what's going on where he's only making
29 as a carpenter my goodness this
economy
he should be making close to three times
that with overtime yeah so i see a gap
here yeah and if you want to change over
to the child care thing erica you gotta
dial it in
for the sake of your family i don't care
what you do but for the sake of your
family you gotta dial it in and make
sure you're gonna make at least as much
make sure
as you're making now
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you